find the eighth term of the sequence
1440 1716
1848 and so on and so forth whose terms
are formed by multiplying the
corresponding terms of two arithmetic
sequences arithmetic sequences always
having trouble saying that properly so
let's think about the two sequences and
then we'll take the products of
corresponding terms to get the terms of
this sequence so maybe one of the
arithmetic sequences starts with a
starts with a and then the next one the
next term in that sequence is going to
be some constant plus a that's what an
arithmetic sequence is it's just a
constant added to each successive term
so it's going to be a
a plus m and then the next term would be
m plus a plus m or it'd be a plus 2m and
if we just kept going we what we care is
all the way to the eighth term because
we're going to take the eighth term of
this sequence multiply it by the eighth
term of the other sequence to get the
eighth term of this sequence over here
so the second term we only added one m
the the third term we added two m's so
the eighth term we're going to add seven
m's one less than the term
the first term we added zero m's so the
eighth term here is going to be is going
to be a plus
a plus
7m that's the eighth term of this
arithmetic sequence now let's do another
one for another arithmetic sequence
maybe that starts at the number b
now the next term is going to be some
constant plus b so let's just call that
b
plus n then the third term will be n
plus b plus n so it'll be b
plus 2 n
and then we go all the way to the eighth
term by the same logic it's going to be
b plus
b plus 7n the difference between each of
these terms is
n
now they tell us that the product of the
corresponding terms of these two
sequences are the terms of this sequence
so a times b so when you take the
product of a and b
we get a times b
a times i'll color code it for here a
times b is going to be equal to 1440
1400
1440
we also know that a plus m
we also know that
a plus m
times b plus n
times b
plus n
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to 17 1716
1716 we also know
we also know that a plus two m
a plus two m
times b plus two n
times b plus two n is going to be equal
to one thousand eight hundred and eight
is going to be equal to
1848 and if we want the eighth term of
this sequence we just have to take this
product right over here so the eighth
term is going to be
is going to be a plus 7m
a plus 7m times b plus 7n
times b plus
b plus 7n now before i even do this it
seems like we have some good information
to at least put some constraints around
our a's b's m's and n's let's just think
about the form that this is going to
take and then maybe we can kind of build
up the numbers as we solve for this
stuff over here
so the eighth term in our sequence is
going to be i'll do this in a new color
it's going to be let's just let's just
multiply these two binomials out a times
b it's going to be a b that's a times b
plus a times 7n so that's plus
seven a n
plus seven m times b so plus seven b m
plus seven m times seven n
seven m times seven n so that's plus
49
plus 49
mn 49
49 mn so this is what we need to figure
out the value of
we need to figure out the value of this
right here well we already know one of
the terms here we already know that a
times b is equal to 1440.
so we're already making some headway
this right here is going to be equal to
1440.
now let's see if we can figure out
anything for these terms over here using
the other information over here so let's
multiply these out
so let me do this once again in a new
color so if i multiply this out i've got
a times b which is a b
plus a times n which is a n
plus m times b or b times m which is b m
plus m times n plus m times n which is
going to be equal to one thousand seven
hundred and sixteen
now we know that a b is fourteen hundred
and forty we know that this is 1440.
so let's see let's subtract 1440 from
both sides of this equation i'll switch
colors again so let's subtract 14
1440 i guess i didn't switch colors from
both sides of this equation these guys
obviously cancel out the left hand side
becomes a n
plus b m
plus m n is equal to
let's see the thousands cancel out we
have a six seventy one minus forty let's
see we have a six minus zero is six
then we can borrow this is a six this is
eleven eleven minus four is seven six
minus four is two one minus 1 is 0. so a
n plus b m plus mn is equal to
276. so we got that information using
this and that that essentially equation
now let's use this equation over here
do this in a
new color i'm running out of colors i'll
do it in a green so we have a times b
which is a b
plus a times two n so it's two a n
plus
two m b times 2m times b so it's plus 2
b m
plus 2m times 2n so plus 4
plus 4
m
n is equal to 1848
well same idea this a b this is 1440.
we can subtract 1440 from both sides of
this equation
i'm running out of space here so i'm
just going to subtract 1440 from the
left and the right side now this
equation becomes
we on the left hand side we're just left
with this stuff over here so we have 2 a
n i'm going to write it over here so it
doesn't look confusing we have 2 a n
plus 2 b m plus 4 m n
is equal to these obviously canceled out
848 minus 440 is 408
is equal to 408 did i do that right 848
yeah 4
408 right and now both sides of this
equation are divisible by 2 so let's
divide both sides by 2. so we have if we
divide everything by 2 you get a n
plus b m
plus
2 m n
is equal to
is equal to 2 0
4.
now these look pretty close it's
actually if we view if we view this as
kind of one variable and this is another
it seems like we can solve for mn and
then we can solve for a n
b m and the reason why that looks useful
the reason why that would be useful is
our final answer we have some multiple
times mn so if we know what mn is we
could put that number here and if we
know what a n plus b m is we just have
to multiply that by 7 we're going to get
this term right over here so let's do
that
let's do that let's solve for
m n and to solve for m n let's subtract
this equation from this equation so let
me do it
in that same color so i'm going to
subtract this from this equation so
multiplied by negative 1 we have
negative
a n
minus b m
minus m n
is equal to negative 276 is equal to
negative 276
and then when we subtract
we get these cancel out these cancel out
and then 2mn minus mn is just going to
be mn
and then 204 minus 276 that's negative
negative 72. so we're able to solve for
mn and that's useful for us because this
expression here is 49 mn so this number
right here this number right here is
negative
that number right there is negative 72.
now what's a n plus b m
well we know that this right here is
negative 72. this right here
is negative 72. so let's add 72 to both
sides of this equation
so plus 72
we get on the left hand side
a n plus b m
these cancel out are is equal to
so 6 plus two is eight seven plus seven
is fourteen
you have a one up there one plus two is
three so it's three hundred and forty
eight so the eighth term in our sequence
which we figured out which we figured
out was this business over here it is
equal to a b
which is the same thing as fourteen
hundred and forty
plus
plus this thing over here plus this
thing which is just the same thing as 7
times let me write it up here
this thing over here in blue is the same
thing as 7 times a n plus b m
now we know that a n plus b m is 348 so
it's 7
times
348 and then finally
finally plus
plus this thing over here plus 49 times
mn
49 or we could say minus 49 times 72. so
let me do so this is you could say
49
times negative 72. this is going to be
the eighth term in our sequence so let's
figure out let's figure out what this
thing
what this thing even is so let's see how
we can let's see how we can do well we
could just multiply it out so 7 times
348
i have no calculator at my disposal 7
times 348 8 times 7 is
56
4 times 7 is 28 plus 3
is or plus 5 is 33
3 times 7 is 21 plus 3 is 24. so this is
2436.
if we add that to 1440 so if you add it
to did i do that right 7 times 8 is 56 7
times 4 is 28 plus 5 is 20 33 it's 30
yep that's right so then we add the 1440
over here we get 6 7 eight
three three thousand eight hundred and
seventy six so that's this whole part
over here that's all of this business
and then we have to take 49 times 72 and
then subtract it from this
so let's take 49
times seventy-two two times nine is
eighteen two times four is eight plus
one is nine stick a zero here nine times
seven is sixty-three
seven times four is twenty-eight plus
six is thirty-four
thirty-four so this is eight
twelve carry the one five and three so
we're gonna subtract three thousand five
hundred and twenty-eight so we get
what do we get here so this becomes a 16
this becomes a six
16 minus eight is eight
six minus two
is four eight minus five is three and
then three minus three is zero so the
eighth term in this sequence the eighth
term in this sequence is going to be i
just wrote it down it is 348.
348. and we're done